[Musique]
bonsoir les amis aujourd'hui vous savez
mirabel et p'tit louis ont été vilain
louis vilain ils n'ont pas voulu manger
leur soupe rue qui était ma foi très
bonne chose
grosos l'aurait bien manger nuit ou la
wii
moi j'aime bien la soupe comme je
descends les voir patron oui vas-y
nounours mais rien qu'un tout petit
moment où nous prenons en plus au plein
d'un corps bonjour les enfants et bien
les enfants
mon petit doigt me dit quelque chose
moi je mange la moitié de ma souvent
alors mirabel qui rata ne me raconte pas
des blagues
tu n'as rien manger du tout petit
mirabel ce n'est pas gentil pourrions le
thé très bonne cette soupe et moi je
l'aurais bien manger je n'ai pas bien
vous avez il y a beaucoup de petits
enfants qui ont faim faim faim et qui
seraient très contents d'avoir une bonne
soupe comme ça je pense bien que c'est
vrai et bien la prochaine fin via
mangerait ma soupe
moi aussi c'est très bien et maintenant
au dodo
allo au plat non non tu nous raconte une
petite histoire petit bond alors une
jolie devinettes
elles sont très gros si elle voyage dans
le ciel les jours de pâques
elle apporte quelques fois une surprise
aux garçons et aux filles qui sont sages
qui mangent bien leur soupe et elles
font du bon donc oui mais et comment le
savez-vous
parce que dans quelques je sais pas et
nous partirons à repenser la campagne et
l'éclat qu'ils apporteront des yeux tout
un chocolat chocolat
oui bien peut-être bien oui il y aura
sûrement un petit poucet nomura
c'est possible moi j'aurais tout ça et
moi aussi bien neuf en chocolat ma fille
et moi aussi j'espère que les cloches ne
l'oublierons pas
aux nuits conscience à demain oui les
enfants à demain bonne nuit
bonne nuit mirabel
[Musique]
mais oui c'est vrai c'est bientôt pâques
et les cloches vont passer dans le ciel
en faisant donc d'une ding dong
et si vous êtes bien sage elle vous
apporteront une petite surprise
et vous partirez peut-être aussi en
vacances à la campagne comme petit louis
et mirabel alors soyez bien sage
nous verrons vous voir demain bonne nuit
les enfants aller vite au dodo et
embrasser bien fort vos parents bogny
produits
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh